[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire le coronavirus a déjà fait
un peu plus de 3000 morts dont quatre en
france sur 130 cas recensés ce matin l'
oms l'organisation mondiale de la santé
a porté le niveau de menace ou degrés
maximum très élevé le virus est assez
contagieux il se répand très vite mais
il semble être moins grave qu'on le
redoutait le site de l' oms recense 40
5300 guérison soit la moitié des 90
milles contamination dans le monde dont
80 milles en chine en france nous n'en
sommes pas encore au stade de l'épidémie
à proprement parler le virus ne circule
pas largement dans la population mais
nous sommes passés vendredi au deuxième
stade le stade en dessous de l'épidémie
quand apparaissent dans plusieurs
régions des grappes deux cas il s'agit
non pas de bloquer le virus ça c'était
le premier stade mais de le freiner de
le retarder
pour gagner du temps et préparer la
riposte alors pour comprendre ce que le
corps navires us deux particuliers
c'était pas la grippe ce n'est pas et
bola ce n'est pas la peste
nous avons évité ellis clément frutos
vous êtes médecins infectiologues à la
pitié salpêtrière en charge de l'unité
d'isolement charles nicolle vous êtes
l'adjointe du professeur éric comme le
chef du service des maladies
infectieuses de la pitié c'est l'une des
deux équipes qui suit le plus grand
nombre de personnes à faire infecter par
le coronavirus en france alors qu est il
de particulier ce coronavirus mais déjà
au niveau épidémiologique donc c'est un
petit peu particulier parce que ce n'est
pas le sar ce donc le virus avec plus de
10 % de mortalité qu'on a connu ce n'est
pas donc plus un coroner virus jean tic
d'un un taux le rhume comme la plupart
des coronavirus donc il a une position
intermédiaire une autre particularité
c'est sa capacité à se déplacer via les
avions puisqu'il est transporté par les
hommes qui se déplacent de plus à même
d'apporter une carte ils m'abordent
commencent eux circulent le coronavirus
dans le
2 c'est à travers les aéroports onda et
c'est ça qui fait qu'il peut aussi
rapidement se répandre aux quatre coins
du monde et dans tous les pays du monde
et on voit très bien qu'il suit la voie
des avions et qu'il se répand à partir
des aéroports
autre particularité c'est là
le contexte d'aujourd'hui la capacité
qu'ont à suivre au jour le jour le
nombre de cas confirmés et
d'avoir ces deux cartes et ses courbes
magnifiques qui peut être assez
anxiogène deuil absolument si on ne sait
pas par rapport à sa maman tu es on nous
donne des chiffres et voilà donc
évidemment le fait que nous on est dans
une population toujours plus nombreuse
dans le monde et avec des zones de 10
paires densité de population
effectivement qui favorise sa
dissémination
et puis on parlera j'espère peut-être un
peu du contexte en france et puis de ses
effets secondaires secondaire plus
politique et non médicaux alors franck
dedieu vous êtes journaliste directeur
adjoint de la rédaction de marianne vous
êtes spécialisé dans l'économie puisque
vous avez été rédacteur en chef adjoint
de l'expansion est professeur d'économie
et de culture générale ali pack business
school dans le dernier numéro de
marianne d'ailleurs vous avez enquêté
sur les conséquences économiques
mondiales du grenat virus on va
l'appeler coronavirus pour faire simple
même si c'en est un particulier alors
qu'est ce que vous voyez vous de de
singulier là dedans de nouveaux
d'inédits de moderne c'est l'ampleur du
de la mondialisation qui est nouvelle
2019 on a fait des comparaisons avec le
strass 2003 et on y finalement le
système dans lequel sincères et la peur
du précédent virus il ya 17 ans et
aujourd'hui est à peu près le même du
point de vue des grands principes
en revanche en ce qui concerne l'ampleur
de la mondialisation on est dans un
autre domaine on se dit finalement 2003
c'était à peu près hier on ne découvre
pas l'importance de la chine dans la
chaîne de production dans son importance
du point de vue de la croissance
économique mondiale en fait si là c'est
un autre monde
entre 2003 et et 2 et aujourd'hui vous
avez les importations françaises
provenant de chine qui ont augmenté de 2
180% 280% presque trois fois plus plus
de trois fois plus donc effectivement
vous vous dites dans ces conditions là
au fond nous sommes dans le même système
de mondialisation oui mais dans la
mesure où il a pris une autre ampleur
eh bien on a changé d'univers on a
changé du verre avec une capacité de
d'enrayer cette machine encore plus
forte notamment après
après on en reparlera mais tout cela
s'insère dans une sorte de du bri
financière de mondialisation des changes
et qui évidemment expose la france parce
qu'on a fait aussi des choix des choix
de délocalisation exposer la france à
une risque de récession si évidemment
une place de la france oui mais alors
justement on y reviendra mais je veux
dire que quelque part en fonction de la
stratégie qu'on eut les pays au regard
de la mondialisation
eh bien ils ont une exposition de
différentes natures l'allemagne n'a pas
le même problème quelque part au à la
chine la même relation naccima l'ex kurt
wallender oui mais voilà vous par
exemple que l'italie qui a besoin de
deux ans en exhortant vive est venue
vers la chine
on peut avoir des problèmes aussi
exactement donc on a on a des
caractéristiques de dépendance
économique à l'égard de la chine qui est
différent en fonction des stratégies
préalable de mondialisation de quelle
manière on s'insère dans ce système là
tu es meilleur vous êtes professeur de
psychologie à l'université paris-x
nanterre est spécialisé en psychologie
sociale
vous travaillez sur la perception des
risques vous collaborez d'ailleurs
régulièrement avec les agences de santé
sur les questions de communication sur
les messages de prévention
alors pour vous à vos yeux avoue de
psychologues qu'est ce qui lie à 2-2
particulier dans cette épidémie de
coronavirus je trouve qu'il s'agit de
surtout de l'amplification de
dans l'estimation des risques en effet
qu on appelle l évaluation des risques
estimé sa probabilité et le risque je
sois même victime est donc en général on
a tendance à surestimer les risques
rares et là typiquement on a affaire à
une surestimation extraordinaire du
niveau de risque par rapport aux
objectifs un objectif par rapport aux
objectifs
donc ça séduit effectivement au fait que
la surmédiatisation fait que je récupère
je vais récupérer en mémoire lorsque
vous dites est ce que je suis exposé moi
même je vais récupérer en mémoire toute
l'information que je peux avoir par les
médias donc je vois des victimes est
effectivement parlé tout à l'heure
il ya beaucoup de victimes assez peu de
gens qui ont réchappé donc on voit
beaucoup les victimes
et donc j'ai tendance à surestimer
largement sachant qu'il ya 3000 par
exemple morts un accident de la route
dont j'aurais plutôt intérêt à avoir
peur qu engendre ma voiture mais j'ai
pas vraiment peur parce que c'est
quelque chose que je connais qui est
familier qui est contrôlable sur lequel
je peux agir alors que le conte à virus
à un risque inconnu au dessous se cache
une pubalgie et robin lors d'actions de
la route c'est juste pour la france les
3 milliards du cordat virus uniquement
dire elle vaut il est par ailleurs une
autre dimension importante ses
dimensions plus psychosocial le fait
qu'au départ cette touche une population
éloignée donc les chinois donc pour le
diable qui est assez circonscrite dans
le temps et d'autant que la contagion
c'est quand même une question de
distance sociale la contagion s'est
effectivement c'est réguler la
d'histoire de la distance sociale et
social cela dit cette licence physique
entre devrait rentrer de ces différences
selon les pays et les cultures d utah
fait dire on pense même à même d'aider
des théoriciens qui nous disent que les
pays où il ya les plus grandes distances
sociales sur par exemple en inde où il
ya des intouchables des gens que je ne
peux même pas touché eh bien ce sont des
pics ont été exposés à des pandémies
donc il ya encore des traces dans la
culture de deux pandémies par les plus
grandes distances sociales est fait pour
ça sans réaction pandémie qui l'ont
connu qu ils ont exploré les hypothèses
d'évolution des 110 vous n'en est pas
sûr antoinette rychner vous êtes suisse
vous êtes romancière et drame et
dramaturge votre nouveau roman
après le monde
2 vient de paraître chez buchet chastel
or c'est un roman post apocalyptique
échos féministe et a inspiré des thèses
des collabos log pablo serving
d'ailleurs on dit beaucoup de bien
lui aussi insistent sur l'entr'aide qui
doit avoir lieu après une catastrophe
tout comme vous c'est votre cas aussi
dans ce roman alors qu'est ce que cette
épidémie de coronavirus à de moderne à
vos yeux
alors le propre des théories de
l'effondrement c'est de mettre en
évidence la vulnérabilité nos sociétés
au regard économiques logistiques de
leur dépendance au pétrole de dépendance
au crédit est aussi la mondialisation
des circuits de production de
consommation dont il a été question donc
dans cette optique évidemment qu'on peut
voir un virus mais je dirai au même
titre que une éruption volcanique une
grande panne généralisée d'électricité
ou un piratage ou un problème dans les
sphères financières on peut le voir
comme un déclencheur de ce qu'on appelle
l'effet domino pour moi en tant que
romancière finalement c'est pas
tellement coronavirus en tant que tel
qui va m'intéresser sait plus ce qui
révèle justement des fragilités d'une
société qui en temps ordinaire se
croient tout puissants tu es alors
justement on va commencer là dessus
puisque les les
les mesures que l'on préconise
aujourd'hui c'est de ne pas s'embrasser
de ne pas se serrer la main ne pas se
rassembler c'est le contraire de
l'entr'aide justement en cas de panne
d'énergie
l'entr'aide ce serait fondamental dans
une danse une catastrophe dans un
effondrement à une théorie de
l'effondrement mais là tout à coup on
est dans un virus c'est à dire en gros
c'est tout ce qui a donné les films de
zombies 1 et dans les films de zombies
leur trend c'est difficile parce que
l'autre c'est à zombie justement où en
tout cas ça pourrait le devenir
vous savez peut-être déjà ne s'est pas
encore là on est peut-être dans un cas
ou l'entr'aide c'est pas bon vous y avez
pensé
oui alors dans ma fiction il ya des cas
d'épidémies
parce que c'est une fiction longue qui
dure sur plusieurs décennies donc il ya
des moments aussi de quarantaine des
scènes aussi de violences de personnes
qui sont exclues parce qu'ils sont
malades et qu on les craint après je
pense que tout ça il faut pas oublier
que c'est un prétexte fictionnel pour
arriver le plus vite possible parce que
ce scénario de l'éruption la catastrophe
soudaine et irréversible qui est au
début de ma fiction et pas à la fin vous
permet surtout d'arriver très rapidement
une forme de table rase qui va me
permettre ensuite de montrer une
reconstruction au nom de différent du
nôtre et c'est après tout quand même ça
qui m'intéressait alors ces derniers
c'est vrai qu'on a vu beaucoup de films
catastrophes des fils de fin du monde
c'est davantage des effets numériques
qui ont fait beaucoup de progrès ces
derniers temps donc on peut visualiser
la fin du monde
une une épidémie comme celle-là elle
s'inscrit dans ce cadre là forcément
quand on est médecin quand elle
psychologue
on est obligé d'y penser on pense tous à
la fin du monde possible à les virus
on en a vu dans man film je crois des
demi-finales contagion le film de
thunderbird actuellement il fait le tour
du monde via la personne ne l'avait vu à
les parents ce ne sera pas ce virus-là
qui sera la cause de l'effondrement de
l'humanité mais il pourra avoir un petit
impact non je voulais revenir un tout
petit peu sur l'entr'aide avec un petit
bémol puisque le fait de porter un
masque en fait quand on est malade c'est
pour protéger les autres donc dans ce
sens là on a une action de se faire
vacciner d'ailleurs et le fait de se
faire faire exactement y venir le fait
de se faire vacciner par exemple contre
la grippe et surtout pour les personnels
soignants c'est un acte altruiste pour
aider les autres c'est plus que pour
s'aider soi-même également
enfin la mobilisation que je peux voir
au quotidien à l'hôpital est partout
pour dépister le maximum de personnes
pour voir les isoler les prendre en
charge
montre que l'élan est là les landes
d'entraidé milla il existe un
même dans ce monde peut-être
d'individualistes d'égoïste
il a toujours bossé peut-être un cliché
après tout sur l'entr'aide mais on sait
que la morale par exemple c'est lié à la
côte est une façon de régler prennent la
coopération or le virus change notre
façon de coopérer que ce soit justement
pour aider dans le sens où je vais
essayer de soutenir ceux y sont victimes
ou les dévaloriser pas parfois mais par
ailleurs aussi m'éloigner mes loyers d
oddo qui est possible que ce virus
change aussi notre logiciel moral plus
au delà de simplement de la simple
protection des maladies qui n'est pas
rien puisque c'est un besoin échapper
aux maladies ou protéger les siens c'est
un besoin humain fondamental
donc il ya ce mélange à la fois de
fondamental c'est à dire vraiment c'est
un besoin fondamental qu'on problème
penser qu'il est très programmée
on dit toujours a touché quelque chose
qui est plus lent ou qui est sensible ou
voilà et en même temps de dix paires
médiatique et donc on est effectivement
cette connexion entre l'hyper médiatique
et le les choses fondamentales voilà les
humeurs familiaux dieu pendant très
longtemps on a associé l'idée la
progression des échanges économiques
amenant à de plus en plus de richesses
c'est un peu l'histoire du capitalisme à
travers les siècles vous pensez que ça
pourrait être l'objet d'un retournement
aujourd'hui tout à kosyam vous voyez les
échanges économiques voilà ce que ça
donne alain transmettre des virus
il faut bien avouer que depuis lehman
brothers depuis la crise financière on
nous fait à chaque fois le coup et et il
m'est arrivé d'y croire c'est à dire de
10 à 7 coups si ça va être différent
lehman brothers c'est fini là il ya le
g7 et le g20
on a considéré qu'il fallait réguler la
finance et donc on allait apprendre
ensuite crise souveraineté des crises
souveraines européennes ont dit à 100
c'est le début de l'europe sociale
ce coup ci le libéralisme et cetera le
chat le
la compétition le dumping social et
fiscal on a compris les irlandais on va
ça se passe pas troisièmement le fameux
retour des états ça y est c'est le
retour des états les entreprises elle
considère quand même les multinationales
qu'à son talent et un petit peu loin et
là elle se retrouve atteindre la sibylle
aux états qui leur viennent en aide
il va y avoir une sorte de répartition
non mais heureusement ou malheureusement
la démondialisation annoncé via la
finance via le budget via le retour de
l'état n'a pas eu lieu mais là on l'a vu
on nous annonce claque de la
mondialisation grâce aux que la grèce
soit cause l'acteur est ce que ce
coup-ci dahan finances a pas marché en
politique ça n'a pas marché
budgétairement ça n'a pas marché
est-ce que la salle on remarque même le
ministre de l'économie je vais te le
maire a évoqué oui il l'a dit en anglais
d'ailleurs ce qui est assez paradoxal
alors qu'il a évoqué bon la question
c'est de savoir au fond est-ce qu'il va
y avoir un tir et un relais politiques
pour dire on peut relocaliser qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire alors déjà un économie
vous regardez comment ça se passe au
niveau des chaînes de valeur c'est être
con à fragmenter le processus de
production entre différents pays de
sorte que vous avez la chine qui paie
qui est incontournable et qui pèse entre
15 et 20% des chaînes de valeur de
fabrique à céline du monde en fait on ne
peut pas très facilement
je dirais se passer comme ça d'un coup
de baguette magique de la chine en
revanche on peut se dire c'est une
question de souveraineté on peut
relocaliser on peut lire il ya des
choses qu'on pourrait relocaliser pour
des questions effectivement d'emplois
mais pour des questions aussi
d'autonomie d'autonomie alimentaire
d'autonomie technologique de
souveraineté ou de santé et de santé
également à partir du moment où ces
larbins de santé mais parce que quelque
part où il ya à chaque fois qu'on est
dans une période de crise est là
monsieur vous pourrez compléter ce que
je veux dire c'est que à partir - rené
sonné à un pic de crise il y à un
élément qui légitime l'intervention de
l'état
rappelez-vous la phrase de
de françois hollande qui dit il y a le
pacte de stabilité
au lendemain des attentats mais il ya
plus important que ça il ya le pacte de
sécurité
et là il dit les 3 % c'est bien gentil
mais on verra plus tard et il a raison
et tout le monde y compris les plus
libéraux au fond c'est légitime
effectivement il ya quelque chose au
dessus alors là on pourrait dire il ya
le pack sanitaires c'est au-dessus
encore alors là c'est quand même une
question de survie
et on se serait parfaitement légitime la
question c'est de savoir jusqu'où est ce
qu'on est dans une sorte de déclaration
d'intention qui marque que moi je
soutiens largement ou alors est-ce qu'il
ya je dirais des puissances économiques
financières qui pourront dire d'attendre
et non en fait on va essayer de
continuer comme avant malgré les
injonctions des politiques malgré les
injonctions des populations on arrive à
avoir une sphère économique et surtout
financière qui s'est autonomisée et qui
finit par je dirais jouer ses propres
règles quitte à ce que à ce qu' il ya
une prochaine crise alors on l'a dit
c'est ce virus est assez contagieux il
se répand assez vite mais il est
beaucoup moins grave qu'on ne le croyait
et tu peux on va dire c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle mais on a l'impression
qu'on sert aujourd'hui de l'hôpital pour
faire de l' isolement de malades qui par
ailleurs ne sont pas mal portants en
fait ils ont le virus mais j'ai
l'impression que à la pitié certes dans
votre service c'est comme ça il ya des
gens bien portants qu'on isole vous avez
tout à fait raison c'est un virus
assez contagieux puisque une personne en
compte en contamine entre 2 et 3 donc
plus contagieuse que la grippe qui tue
moins qu'on le pensait puisqu'au début
on ne recensait que les cas les plus
sévères en chine et donc on avait des
taux de mortalité élevé et maintenant
qu'on commence à dépister des gens ont
de moins en moins symptomatiques voir
des gens qui n'ont quasiment aucun
symptôme et qu'on a des pistes et parce
qu'ils sont le père la mère le fils la
femme d'un des cas hospitalisés
on se rend compte que finalement il ya
beaucoup plus de porter compenser et de
ce fait la mortalité diminue et pour
arriver peut-être maintenant vers les 1
% c'est quand même au dessus aussi de la
mortalité de la grille néanmoins vous
avez raison nous nous retrouvons nous
soignant à l'hôpital dans une situation
un petit peu incongru où nous nous
occupons plus tellement de malades mais
deux personnes qu'il faut isoler et
c'est aussi ce qui nous est demandé
du reste de la population pour essayer
encore d'enrayer ce qui peut l'être
on sait que on n'échappera pas à
l'épidémie en france mais en gros on
peut le retarder on essaie de la
retarder en dépistant un maximum de
personnes et en isolant les positif bien
entendu on est à la limite de notre
système
vous le savez l'hôpital public déjà
aller mal avant on était déjà en
sous-effectif tous un petit peu fatigué
donc ça vient rajouter tout est dans
l'urgence on s'adapte bien évidemment on
prend en charge les personnes on se
retrouva à dépister des dizaines et
bientôt des centaines de personnes on
reçoit plus de 1000 appels par jour je
la portais des démarches des scaphandres
comme les chinois on voit les photos on
voit des tous les médecins avec des
scaphandres dans les scaphandres 6 qui
fout la trouille aussi des scaphandres
c'est plutôt en laboratoire quand on
manipule directement le virus nous nous
avons évidemment des
détenus accueillis sur blues avec des
masques ffp2 des lunettes des gants des
charlottes des surchaussures mais encore
une fois c'est pour éviter de disséminer
donc voilà on se retrouve là dans mon
service par exemple avec une vingtaine
de personnes en isolement donc ils sont
pas ils sont pas spécialement malade en
tout cas elles n'ont pas de critères
d'hospitalisation mais pour essayer de
retarder la transmission
il n'y a pas dans le personnel de
soignants qui déjà vous manquer de
personnel il n'y a pas de cas déjà de
gens infectés qu'il faut retenir des cas
dans d'autres hôpitaux c'est le risque
c'est lorsqu'on a pris en charge une
personne sans savoir qu'elles étaient
contaminés et quand on l'apprend de
trois jours après ben on rappelle toutes
les personnes qui ont été amenées à s'en
occuper effectivement dans ces cas là
des personnels ont été identifiés à la
pitié aujourd'hui il n'y en a pas à ce
que je sache
mais parce que nous nous avons pris les
mesures dès l'arrivée des cas suspects
donc et elle ce qu'on meurt du cornât
virus est ce qu'on meure d'autres balles
a dit qu'on avait et parce qu'on attrape
le cornac virus tout à coup c'est balade
ils emportent alors il semble
effectivement que des personnes qui en
meurent sont les personnes les plus
fragiles donc il ya un gradient avec
l'âge plus on est âgé plus on risque
d'en mourir à plus de 50 ans on a une
mortalité plus élevé qu'à plus de 60 ans
et à + 80 encore plus élevés et les
enfants et inversement les enfants
ne présenterait pas de formes sévères et
puis en plus de l'âge et à d'autres
facteurs l'obésité le diabète toujours
les mêmes le tabagisme
et puis toutes les causes
d'immunodépression donc c'est un petit
peu toujours pareil en espèces de
sélection naturelle et ce sont les plus
faibles qui surplomberont tu es meilleur
oui mais c'est parce que là ce sont
impressionnant puisqu'il déshumanise on
peut tourner à faire une situation
d'eads et imad déshumanisant donc ysl
même susceptible de provoquer donc des
visions très émotionnel très émotionnel
et on sait que quand je suis mauvais
émotionné je le transmets aux autres
donc de créer une sorte d'anxiété lors
d'une recherche très connus où on
présente des serpents par exemple à des
gens ils ont peur évidemment l'anxiété
et ensuite à prendre des fleurs ils ont
peur des fleurs qui ne sont pas
familières et donc le danger c'est
l'idée que lorsqu'on a une peur quelques
pas latence à se diffuser dans d'autres
secteurs et donc je peux avoir peur des
fleurs un peu bizarre si a pas le moment
où je suis moi même en état en état de
peur et de fait c'est à partir de ce
moment là je suis donc cette cette
anxiété fait que tout ce que ce que je
vais interpréter va être traitée sous un
angle émotionnel et puces ou à non
rationnel d'alias et le carré jean
salesse aux théories du complot on a dit
que c'est rome qui a effectivement
volontairement mis en place en chine ce
ce virus pour contrer la puissance
économique chinoise par exemple donc
effectivement ça peut me rassurer
quelque chose qui est contrôlable un
système justification d'explication et
voilà donc je sais pourquoi le virus et
d'un et quand on voit des gens avec les
basques les plus classiques un concept
habitué à voir en occident depuis
l'épidémie de strass d'ailleurs un en
2003 on a vu tout à coup des avions
venant d'asie avec des gens qui
sortaient avec ce masque qu'on
connaissait peu encore à l'époque
est ce que c'est un facteur inquiétant
rassurant parce que après tout s'il
porte un masque c'est pour nous protéger
vous nous l'avez dit mme en face ils
portent un masque c'est qu'ils ont été
en contact avec ou à proximité de gens
qui à risque et puis en plus on nous dit
que finalement ce match qui ne sert pas
à grand-chose fois qu'il aurait une
autonomie de 3 heures
c'est vrai d'une chaire pendant trois
heures ou blood trois heures on peut le
jeter il doit être porté par les malades
pour éviter qu'ils ne transmettent à via
les gouttelettes voilà mais ça évite pas
la contamination manu portet et
effectivement il a une durée de vie
entre voilà trois quatre heures qui fait
qu'il faudrait le changer régulièrement
puisque bout d'un moment il perd son
caractère de filtre est effectivement
pour les personnes non malades il n'a
pas pas beaucoup d'intérêt en tant que
tel franck dedieu le facteur plus
important si la familiarité donc c'est
pas le fait qu'ils aient un masque oui
j'en ai pas c'est que je sois familier
sûr qu'en france la production du masque
est récente et donc effectivement elle
peut que ça peut paraître menaces sont
de la partie au moment où ça commence à
se diffuser c'est la familiarité quelles
principales et en asie c'est très
heureux résidents la route ou le saurons
nous masque ne fera pas de dieu que
effectivement là ce que vous dites c'est
que il ya une forme d'irrationalité qui
finit tout de même dans l'humanité parce
rationaliser par se rétablir
le problème par exemple avec les marchés
financiers la notion de
d'autoréalisation c'est que en soit le
réel ne les intéresse plus c'est à dire
que la peur du réel et la peur du
changement ce passage des fleurs non
familière plutôt des serpents aux fleurs
d'un familière sacré déjà quelque chose
réellement dire qu'à partir du moment où
on se dit il y avait ce dont j'ai peur
au nom de la gestion du risque et au nom
du fait qu'on fait tous à peu près la
même chose
eh bien il faut que je réagisse en
premier et donc il ya un phénomène de
panique qui n'est pas forcément il ne
s'en sert pas forcément dans une logique
de réalité mais qui finit par être auto
réalisant et qui produit en revanche des
effets bien réel et réalise que vous ne
tentant de dire c'est que les marchés
financiers je suis métaphore du
coronavirus tout le corps d'un virus est
une métaphore de marché vous dire c'est
peut-être les deux et ça va être dans la
catastrophe il est par exemple la sur
les marchés
il ya une question qui se pose c'est
difficile d'y répondre
c'est qu'habituellement m'ont dit vous
savez dans ces cas là l'or devrait
monter l or ne mentent pas et ils les
mêmes depuis une semaine en baisse alors
vous savez nous a dit chaque frappe
l'europe
baysse un petit peu alors si je
coordonne sa corne nana oui mais dans
l'univers des marchés cette question là
ça c'est nouveau
quelque part c'est le passage aux fleurs
qu'on ne connaît pas ça c'est nouveau
mon dieu si même la valeur refuge
l'espèce de deux voiliers de cette
sûreté de l'or voilà du cassandre finit
aussi par nous échapper là quelque part
l'heure est grave qu'est ce qu'on va
faire
eh bien on va se poser la question
pendant la pause et on se retrouve juste
après pour continuer ce débat
[Musique]
le pire je pense en tout cas
politiquement pour l'union européenne
c'est que ça se passe bien pour les
anglais il y aura peut-être un effet
boule de neige si l'italie sort vous
avez un éclatement de l'euro et de
l'union européenne dans les mois qui
suivent
l'euro s'est pas seulement un projet
financier c'est un projet politique
aussi le rhône fonctionne pas sinon
n'auraient pas eu ce groupe elle a eu
avec la grèce je suis partiellement pas
d'accord sur l'échec de l'euro on
maintient la grèce en commun à mon avis
c'est une bonne chose
vous pouvez pas vous réjouir d'avoir
votre pays qui est sous perfusion sous
assistance respiratoire en permanence
[Musique]
à
oui
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques dans notre pays
et sur ces dossiers sensibles je vais
partager avec vous mon interprétation
quelle que soit la qualité expertise
indéniable nos soldats ne peuvent gagner
la guerre pour la raison que je vais
maintenant est ce que peuvent faire un
peu plus de 5000 militaires français à
l'efficacité certes reconnu sur une zone
aussi vaste même renforcé par cinq mille
soldats promis par les pays vieux zinc
valait c'est là où les problèmes ont
commencé
les déclarations récentes des politiques
des spécialistes des experts des
militaires montre bien que nous sommes
face à une incompréhension totale entre
les différents acteurs
si la france n'a pas la volonté
nécessaire pour assurer la réalisation
de ses objectifs et de les accompagner
parce qu'il ne s'agit pas d'imposer il
s'agit de convaincre et d'accompagner il
est à craindre que nous terminions
enlisé dans un conflit sans fin
[Musique]
nous continuons notre débat sur le corps
anna virus épidémies modernes typique du
21e siècle avec elif clément frutos qui
est infectiologues à la pitié
salpêtrière avec franck dedieu le
directeur adjoint de la rédaction de
marianne
il est spécialisé en économie avec
thierry meyer professeur de psychologie
à l'université paris-x nanterre
il travaille sur la perception des
risques et antoinette rychner qui est
suisse romancière et dramaturge et dont
le nouveau roman après le monde vient de
paraître chez buchet chastel
c'est un roman sur l'effondrement alors
antoinette vouloir rebondir
oui et dans une fiction d'effondrement
il ya bien sûr l'idée que tout à coup la
finitude devient s'impose notre notre
condition de finitude s'impose je pense
que dans nos sociétés actuelles on n'est
pas du tout familier justement de cette
idée que la maladie puisse tuer thierry
meyer l'a bien dit on a beaucoup plus il
ya beaucoup plus de morts par la route
par exemple que par la maladie en tout
cas dans d'autres idées parce que dans
les chiffres se serait pas tout à fait
vrai mais pourtant dans notre histoire
il ya eu des épidémies
en 1300 présente la peste et je pense
qu'on continue de le porter en nous mais
comment on peut réactiver sa comment on
peut accepter aussi parce que finalement
d'un point de vue numérique trois morts
en quatre mois maintenant en france
qu'est-ce que ça déclenche chez nous et
comment on pourrait aussi se donner les
moyens peut-être symbolique culturelle
d'être plus serein avec cette idée de la
mort on a on est aussi avec l'idée des
progrès de la médecine qui ont été
absolument fabuleux au cours de deux des
dernières décennies au contenu du
dernier siècle en particulier et on se
dit bien là comme par exemple quand on
est au stade 2 on essaye de retarder le
virus on se dit que ben c'est pour
trouver une riposte à dire avec ça et on
se dit tous d'ailleurs qu'on va trouver
un bac 5 je parlais du film de steven
soderbergh beaucoup de gens ont regardé
depuis quelques semaines depuis le début
de l'épidémie de coronavirus telle
épidémie d'une violence d'une brutalité
d'une mortalité infiniment supérieur à
ce qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
mais on attend record il trouvait la
main avec ça dans le film ces avantages
des films c'est tout va très vite
et là c'est pareil on se dit on va
trouver un match de toute façon ça va
être réglée assez vite d'ailleurs il
faut noter qu'un virus qui tue
rapidement et
et de manière très importante ne se vit
survivra pas très longtemps et
raccourcir à sa propre épidémie ah oui
donc le film de souabe airbags il est
réaliste dans ce sens-là virus comme
celui du sart skov de donc le corps n'a
un virus dont on parle ce soir il est
intermédiaire c'est-à-dire qu'ils tuent
mais pas trop il se transmet bien et
donc il y a des chances de durer et
peut-être même de devenir endémique
ah oui alors les vrais noms des bic
c'est à dire de perdurer à petit à la
petite échelle on continue avec bien sûr
des pics saisonniers comme pour tous ces
virus d'accord concernant les vaccins
c'est pas si facile
vous le savez dans d'autres virus comme
la le vih la dengue on est toujours à la
recherche de vaccins à la fois efficace
et non plus dangereux pour ceux qui sont
vaccinées que ceux qui ne le sont pas
pour le coran navires us voilà les
experts les experts estiment qu'on aura
absolument rien d'efficace avant au
moins juillet 2021 donc d'ici là cette
bouffée épidémique actuel sera sera
largement passé alors parmi les mesures
auquel on assiste en france aujourd'hui
on a vu qu'on on a lu lé s'attendent de
salons professionnels on a ride
raccourci le salon de l'agriculture on a
on annule le salon de l'immobilier à
cannes on annule le salon du livre à
paris mais en revanche les grands musées
reste ouvert le louvre reste ouvert
enfin tout sauf quand les employés et
décident eux mêmes de se mettre en
retrait mais on trouve logique de
laisser ouvert des très grands musées
qui attire énormément de touristes comme
le comme le louvre et de fermer le salon
du livre à paris vous l'expliquer d'une
certaine manière dans un bâtiment
universités qui a douze mille personnes
dont des années 60 et je le dis toujours
aux étudiants vous avez plus de chances
d'attraper le rhume que encore navires
us et il se pose la question mais il n'y
a pas d'eau chaude chez dans ce bâtiment
encore on est donc arrivé à l'université
et je n'y a aucun problème puisque le
constable et malo chaude n'a aucun
impact sur le jeu nous fait d'avoir du
savon pendant pendant plus de vingt
secondes qui va fait que va faire qu'il
va faire un effet donc effectivement il
est différence d'échelle à ça c'est
considérer de la même manière le préfet
de l'oise fermer les marchés en plein
air mais il est ouvert les grandes
surfaces et les hypermarchés uzi que
après tout le petit détaillant le petit
maraîcher à une force de
d'une capacité de se plaindre bien
moindre que un hypermarché par exemple
sans que ceux-ci ont fermé et l'autre
pas si on regarde la communication
gouvernementale je trouve qu'elle est
relativement bien maîtrisé puisqu'il est
important la communication de coller des
experts soit crédible donc là je pense
qu'ils laissent la place comme aide à
diageo jerada santé les les instructions
pour que nous chaque jeu directeur des
communications du 8ème au chef de
service ne parle pas directement au
public mais que la formation soit
transmise est gérée à l'échelle
collective les consignes sont
relativement claires il ya eu des
progrès du côté de là mais vous trouvez
anti nguyên thi 2000 avait raison entre
l'anr on a moins de risques selon tami
n'est que dans un milieu confiné
absolument aberrant ces deux fermes les
marchés alors qu'on sait très bien que
ça va vraiment posé des problèmes à des
petits détaillants alors cela dit si
c'est grave il faut le faire mais quand
même
mais quand même maman on laisse ouvert
les grandes surfaces ça paraît dingue à
ce que le y aurait pas une logique
économique la data couche de la même
manière on pourra dire pourquoi adultes
ont le barathon effet de faire me trompe
pas disneyland à moi je suis parti d'un
a priori de de confiance quand même et
de compétences des gens qui désirent
effectivement on me disait les
supermarchés peuvent continuer à
fonctionner et puis en revanche pas des
manifestations entendre quelqu'un de
votre compétence votre niveau 10 c'est
aberrant
la samba fall parce que je me suis il
doit y avoir une réponse pas forcément
eux ils savent bon et c'est quelque part
je pense que ça suppose thème la
confiance le fait que le gouvernement je
délègue la gestion habile aussi placer
les intérêts que de big three c'est
comme dans les dents de la mer ils se
faisaient dans les eaux de la mer la
lutte il est le maire de la ville veut
pas faire mais voilà les élus
veut pas dire qu'il ya un requin qui tue
les gens parce qu'il attend le retour
des touristes pour le week end du 4
juillet on a ramé louvre on en vient
forcément en déduire cela quand on
entend un spécialiste dire c'est
aberrant effectivement on se dit il ya
deux poids deux mesures qui lié à
l'importance et à la puissance
économique et financière des acteurs
maintenant à ce jeu là on peut aussi
s'en mordre les doigts parce que aussi
que ça va contre la transition vers une
autonomie l'autonomie dont vous parliez
tout à l'heure puisque des détails on au
marché ce serait plus des producteurs
locaux que les suisses qui ce qui va
approvisionner les supermarchés vient à
manquer ce qu'il faut faire
politiquement pour obtenir cette
autonomie politiquement je pense que le
gouvernement a décidé de déléguer
quelque part presque la communication au
jour le jour à des spécialistes pour se
donner une certaine manière on a c'est
un peu l'antithèse de lusine de rouen
lubrizol
quelque part on se disait le ministre
est un état était sur le devant de la
scène
ils ont été prompts 4 à se mobiliser
quelques heures après l'explosion et
c'est là on a l'impression que au
contraire on va dire on va donner la
parole à la délègue à des experts il
savait pourquoi puisque dans le cadre du
brise hall ça n'a pas empêché les
complots les théories du complot de
prospérer et effectivement vous avez un
lieu quelque part je verrai une sorte de
tragédie avec unité de temps et de lieu
là c'est beaucoup plus diffus donc
effectivement on a l'impression que le
le le
on se dit que le politique et à
l'obligation de transmettre le bébé la
patate chaude si j'ose dire aux aux
compétences sanitaire dans le cas du
préfet de l'oise pour justifier la
fermeture le laisser ouvert les
grossières de chauffage et un disque
parce que les gens circulent dans les
grandes surfaces ne stagne pas part aux
quatre j'imagine montpellier peut-être
pas pensé
si tout le monde respectait les les
mesures annoncées c'est à dire quand on
est malade on reste chez soi
effectivement il y aurait quand même
et les gens le font quand même
globalement des gens le font de même que
les gens moi je suis toujours surpris de
voir des gens qui acceptent d'être
hospitalisée quinze jours dans une
petite pièce à pression négative ça
c'est les gens qui s'y connaît le combi
j'ai vu des gens alors expliquer ce que
c'est que les pièces à pression négative
c'est à dire c'est les pièces où on peut
pas ouvrir les fenêtres
c'est ça alors ouvrir les fenêtres un
moyen aussi de faire alors que chez toi
en priorité il vaudrait mieux ouvrir la
fenêtre 90e on peut ouvrir les fenêtres
ah bon mais le fait d'avoir ces fameuses
pression négative et vite que quand on
ouvre les portes par contre les
gouttelettes et des particules virales
puisse si à l'extérieur de la chambre
donc la save reste amateur de lâcher
envoyé un système d'évacuation
voilà mais il n'y a pas assez de chambre
à pression négative dans les hôpitaux
pour accueillir tous les malades
aujourd'hui
donc ils sont également d'entendre mais
enfin les voilà les gens acceptent de
rester confinés et c'est très difficile
à vivre et le font encore une veille
mais vous serez à la blague du
gouvernement est-ce que ça a un sens à
la fois de de fermer des endroits et en
même temps de laisser
le métro le train et l'avion
fonctionnaient est ce que tout cela a un
sens il faut bien faire quelque chose
faut bien interdire quelque chose quoi
c'est la mode
je sais pas comment qu'elles soient
opérationnelles on peut se dire sur le
marché les gens c'est un lieu de
conversation de sociabilité où on se
pare d'or à m non mais oh je chantais de
trajet sur un mécanisme de protection g
de produit je protège la crédibilité de
dudu message on est tous tendance à
faire ça on a l'impression qu'il faut
forcément prendre une décision interdit
à quelque chose sinon on n'est pas
crédible sinon on a on peut laisser
l'impression qu'on ne fait pas son
travail alors que d'après ce que vous
dites on sent que c'est pas tellement
lac se passe le travail au fond c'est
une responsabilité de chacun si on se
sent pas bien à ne pas sortir et ça
reste c'est pas en interdisant le
marathon est pas disneyland qu'on va
changer pour allart soir je crois que
les gens sont quand même capable de
celle là où l entraide c'est là où est
la responsabilité de chacun c'est vrai
quand vous dites je ne sais pas quelque
part on peut pas supporter venant de
spécialistes elle sera on ne peut pas à
supporter mettez vous à la place d'un
ministre
je ne sais pas non vous pouvez pas faire
profession de votre ignorance et pas
possible vous devez est donc quelque
part belle ministre doit décider et y at
il une part d'arbitraire
moi j'avais l'impression que non mais
maintenant j'apprends que oui c'est vrai
que c'est assez embêtant on ne peut pas
supporter cette phrase je ne sais pas
oui je crois qu'il faut c'est petit lait
belliard zone c'est un spécialiste de la
prévention des risques
et puis surtout de la prévention alors
avec toutes les agences de santé vous
avez travaillé avec elle là en
l'occurrence est ce que qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
car dd déjà j'en parlais au début il ya
des différences ça ça illustre listes de
comptes de deux systèmes de contrôle
social c'est ce qui se passe en chine et
systèmes autoritaires chinois n'est pas
du tout le mode de régulation
de plus qu'on choisit ici vous êtes
libres d'aller de plus du bon ben voilà
donc graduellement sa renverser son
compte et des pays qui ont moins un
système sanitaire beaucoup plus fragile
que le calcul de nos dents qu'est la
vulnérabilité peu de la perception des
réalités la pète vraiment avéré du fait
que les gens ne seront pas protégés la
pression on est plutôt tranquille avec
ça parce qu'on sait qu'à côté on a un
système de protection sociale or social
déjà ce qui n'est pas le cas aux états
unis parce que beaucoup servi et
beaucoup de beaucoup de 10 millions de
personnes qui n'ont pas de protection
sociale et donc qu'il a craint du grenat
virus change de le totalement du fait
qu'ils c'est la crainte de ne pas avoir
les moyens de se protéger
en france on a quand même c'est le
protection cette protection sociale qui
nous permet d'être plus serein dire à la
fois le risque on semblait même si on
alors c'est vrai qu'on est l'émotion
entend s'adapter ce qui est spécifique
d'une émotion se condense à la partager
dès que je suis jean émotions il en a
parlé tous du canal du centre de ça
c'est un mécanisme très connu ce fait le
partage social d'émotion je leur
souhaite g d'émotion gens parlent à
d'autres et donc ça a tendance à
amplifier et du fait qu'on est protégé
finalement en france voilà on arrive à
réguler dans d'autres pays fait
attention si les choix de crise est
internationale on peut avoir des
réactions très tout à fait différente
d'abord principe en afrique il n'ya pas
du tout de protection ou peut avoir des
phénomènes aussi de jeu par les dates
est un groupe on a là on n'a pas
beaucoup parlé des le fait que ce que ça
touche aussi des groupes sociaux les
chinois qui peuvent lier à lapin soit
l'apparence physique ou à la voix ou là
on atteint il ya récemment il ya eu d
une interdiction de voilà ce que sont
les membres d'un sur un paquebot par
exemple on est mal vue sur donc on à
l'etrat gré d'avoir les risques d un pas
qu'on parlait catastrophisme et de des
impacts en termes d' agression entre
groupe du fait que l'armée y est réel ou
avérées ou pas certains groupes peuvent
être conservées comme nation donc s'il
ya quand même un danger en france sept
protos et protection sociale nous
protège de beaucoup de choses il ya
quand même dans le métro on a vu des
gens se s'éloigner ou se protéger quand
il y avait des gens susceptibles d'être
des touristes chinois dans les mé
d'italiens c'est plus difficile c'est
plus difficile
et même s'il n'était pas par ailleurs ni
chinois ni les touristes
évidemment
juste vous pariez d'afrique est ce que
dans un pays où on peut mourir de faim
est ce que tu es très la crainte d'un
virus intermédiaires comme quand j'avais
vu c'est peut-être pas secondaire je me
demande si on n'est pas aussi dans une
parano de pays riches quoi avec nos
besoins nos besoins essentiels qui sont
satisfaits donc une menace qui qui qui a
quand même relative la gère tout à coup
nous nous fait paniquer de ces nouveaux
et on ne sait pas encore comment le
prendre en charge on n'a pas encore les
traitements efficaces n'a pas encore les
vaccins donc on est démuni
donc c'est ça qui nous montrent une
autre voilà notre vulnérabilité qui fait
peur la vulnérabilité vous l'avez dit
elle est également économique alors le
risque de il ya un risque de crise
industrielle puisqu'on l'a dit la chine
c'est du sinn du monde donc il ya les
allemands pour fabriquer leurs machines
outils qu'ils exportent ensuite travers
le monde et de tabac en chine ils ont
besoin de la chine pour nous c'est à
dire que c'est devenu je dirais pas la
chine n'est pas devenu une sorte d'
opportunités comme quelque part dans les
eaux début des années 2000 c'est une
opportunité volkswagen d'isabey tiens on
va pouvoir vendre pleine nature et c'est
là c'est plus ça c'est à dire que c'est
devenu un élément essentiel du système
productif et des stratégies économiques
de la chaîne de montage
grosso modo de chacun des pays c'est à
dire que vous avez le tout tout l'
architecture le processus productif
français est fondé sur l'idée qu'on va
importer des produits venant de chine
qu'on pourra proposer aux consommateurs
à moindre coût mais en revanche
eh bien on bridera l'augmentation des
salaires ont fait ça c'est le timbre et
à sion mais de survivre avec d'un taux
de chômage élevé donc quelque part les
allemands ont se sont dits dans on va
faire une politique très mercantiliste
on va pouvoir vendre exporter nos
voitures et
on va quand même pour avoir un coût
relativement on va en revanche des
produits ici et non pas ceux stratégie
française aussi je n'ai pas par là mais
c'est c'est plutôt de produire à
l'extérieur vous allez les productions à
l'intérieur qu'ils soient ensuite
réimporter donc effectivement vous avez
vous vous réimporter entre guillemets
compris la viabilité dit compris des
pièces dont on se sert ensuite pour
fabriquer des cheminements absolument
donc c'est vrai que ça c'est une
stratégie française qui diffère de la
société de la stratégie allemande qui
est une stratégie non pas de production
sur le pays mais de production en
allemagne pour pouvoir l'exporter c'est
d'ailleurs pour cela qu'ils se sont dit
comme on veut aller plus avant dans
cette stratégie mercantiliste de
production chez nous pour un but
d'exportation et bien on va essayer de
tenir les salaires allemands et donc
quelque part la demande intérieure
allemande n'a pas été très forte mais on
a pu vivre avec ça entre parenthèses
cette demande intérieure forte des
allemands qui sait je dirais qu'il s'est
amenuisée par l'absence de pouvoir
d'achat parce qu'on dit au pape ou de
monter trop on fait des lois de
flexibilité du travail et bien ce sont
les français qui travaillaient avec des
allemands qui exporter des produits
allemands qui ont pu gerrican ont
souffert parce que les allemands n'ont
pas pu acheter faute de demande
intérieure suffisante
là y aurait quelques lm produits
risquent de manquer bientôt parce que
justement il n'y a plus la chine pour
les fabriquer ou en tout cas l'iphone
l'iphone parham vous allez 80% de la
production des métaux et sont essentiels
à la fabrication des matériaux des
tricks et c'est un rat qui sont je
dirais dans les mains de lachine vous
avez tord à l'autre qu'on fabriquait
enfin qu on raffine est en france mais
qu'on a exporté là bas parce que ça
pollue voilà vous avez 53 pour cent de
la production mondiale d'acier alors
vous allez dire mais on n'a qu'à faire
de l'acier on ferme des usines chez nous
on n'a qu'à les airs et ouvrir sauf que
effectivement ça change radicalement le
processus de production je pense que on
peut être
imaginez peut-être à cette occasion la
repenser les choses en terme de
relocalisation
en plus de ça ou vous l'avez vous l'avez
dit non seulement il ya une dimension
sanitaire
il ya aussi une dimension écologique où
on retrouvera celte eu peur un peu à la
fois de la fin du monde ça imaginez
qu'il a tout ça soit réglé dans quatre
mois de la rapatrier chez nous la
fabrication d'acier mais c'était
exactement ce que je disais à mes débuts
c'est exactement ce que je disais en
début d'émission c'est à dire
qu'effectivement à partir du moment où
on a résolu plus ou moins la crise de
lehman brothers
on arrive nous lui plus ou moins la
crise grecque est bien effectivement on
repart comme avant parce que il ya je
dirais une problématique qui mettrait
des années à se repenser et puis une un
problème qu'on arrive à résoudre plus ou
moins du mois mettre la poussière sous
le tapis au bout de quatre mois
donc effectivement c'est peut-être
reparti pour un tour internet reste un
regret tout même les risques à court
terme mais les risques à moyen ou long
terme
on sait bien qu'on n'a plus les réserves
en matières premières qu'elles sont en
train de s'épuiser les métaux rares
qu'il faut justement même pour les
technologies renouvelables une maison
basse consommation c'est bourré de
technologie pour avoir des capteurs
thermiques pour avoir les stores qui se
ferme selon la météo
tout ça ça consomme des métaux rares
kokkola de moins en moins une eco race
est extrêmement leur extraction c'est
pour ceux qui sont rares d'ailleurs ça
nécessite des dégâts énormément et j'ai
l'impression de toute façon un moment
donné les les transports qui sont
actuellement à très bas coût ces coups
là ils vont augmenter donc j'ai
l'impression que la question de la
relocalisation c'est une question de
délai peut-être que ce sera pas le
coronavirus qui va qui va faire changer
ça mais tôt ou tard on sait bien que
d'ici la moitié du siècle il faudra il
faudra prendre le problème à bras le
corps et lisieux paiement faillir à
d'autres épidémies
voilà ce n'est pas celle là je vous
évoquez tout à l'heure la
l'accroissement de la population on peut
rouler envoyé à la carte que tout à
l'heure la population mondiale mais
également là je voudrais revenir sur
cette carte que vous nous avez montré au
fonction de l'accroissement de la
population mondiale
on voit que les épidémies au fonds
servent de régulateur c'est ça alors
voilà il ya eu des oscillations voit un
petit peu en bas de la courbe si vous
montez la montre est là d'ailleurs ces
oscillations sont plutôt dues aux
changements au climat et aux périodes de
changement climatique des périodes
chaudes et froides
si on prend la courbe de la france on
voit vraiment l'impact des grandes
épidémies voilà tel que la peste le
choléra et puis égal à chaque fois qu'il
ya des crocs également les guerres et ce
qui est intéressant enfin il ya une
carte sur l'effondrement
voilà ce qui est intéressant c'est de
voir dans la théorie
développé par le couple me doses qui se
passe lorsqu'on atteint l'équilibré
c'est à dire que le milieu la charge de
la population à moment donné à un impact
tel que elle elle va à sa propre perte
alors l'idéal ce serait la courbe de
gauche c'est à dire que on se rend
compte que on n'a pas une limite de ce
qu'on peut exploiter et à ce moment là
on maîtrise notre propre population ça
c'est un coq de gauche lacombe 2 h entre
je sais quoi on a dépassé
malheureusement se sait pointillés c'est
un peu l'image de yves paccalet avec les
lapins dans la clairière fermé donc les
la passe se reproduise c'est ce qu'à un
moment ils ont ils ont plus rien à
manger donc à trois solutions soit un
moment donné ils se disent bon on est
assez nombreux si on continue comme ça
on n'aura pas assez à manger
donc on s'arrête on s'arrête c'est
l'idéal ce que quelque part la
population humaine n'aurait dû faire
quand elle a atteint c'est 100 premiers
millions ou son premier milliard la leur
est dû se dire ok bon maintenant on va
peut-être arrêter d'avoir plus d'un
enfant au maximum deux parcours on a
continué et si on continuait de manière
exponentielle ce serait la courbe de
droite
là je n'arriverai à l'effondrement
fiscale moment on aurait pu les
ressources voilà s'il n'y a plus assez
de pétrole ne peuvent pas nourrir la
population
donc on arriverait à ça mais la courbe
du milieu ce sont les oscillations alors
une catastrophe naturelle l'une une
guerre une épidémie il y en aura
d'autres et des beaucoup plus grave que
celle là ça tu ça donnera donc une
diminution transitoire et partiel alors
on sait pas de quel niveau ça dépendra
des épidémies qui permettra de diminuer
un petit peu la pression sur
l'environnement et sur les ressources et
de nouveau la population revenir à et
voilà c'est vers ça on a l'air de tomber
ce ne sera pas suffisant pour empêcher
voilà les dégâts déjà fait par
l'humanité sur d'autres planètes
le malthusianisme n'est pas née dans la
tête d'un pasteur mais en fait est
totalement naturelle j'ajouterai quand
même pour
relativisez votre approche c'est que
finalement le seul pays qui a voulu
maîtriser sa démographie c'est quand
même la chine d'où vient paradoxe le
court aux navires us donc il y a quand
même c'est pas aussi simple que ça la
relation entre la production de richesse
potentielle le la population on peut
aussi croire au progrès et de se dire
finalement nous avons les moyens alors
il ya des géographes qui le disent
spécialiste de l'agriculture on a les
moyens de nourrir diviseur de l'humain
qu'aujourd'hui valent largement
vraiment je suis pas un spécialiste de
ces questions là mais je crois que bien
que l'éruption d'un virus soit une sorte
de de déterminisme démographique pour
faire baisser par accident la population
est prorogé la survie de l'espèce c'est
pas dans ce sens là que je voulais le
dire je voulais dire que les zones de
forte densité de population favorise la
dissémination des maladies et les
mobilise la mobilisation aussi des
populations quand les colons sont
arrivés en amérique ou en australie etc
ils ont amené avec eux leur maladie
salade et trick face à tuer probablement
80 % des gens qui étaient déjà là donc
ça a toujours existé et c'est voilà
c'est si nous on se met dans des
situations de surpopulation ou de deux
paquebots où il ya quatre mille
personnes sur un bateau ou de deux cars
de touristes et je ne sais quelle autre
situation avec des gens avec moins d'un
mètre carré par personne forcément moi
je les ai vécus avec les camps de
réfugiés aussi avec médecins sans
frontières ont créé les conditions de
des épidémies j'ai eu à gérer des
épidémies de dengue de typhoïde
donc voilà c'est ça que je voulais dire
on les accepte d'autant que moi j'étais
assez osé au total 5 ou 2 juillet 2021
vous avez dit finalement on pourra pas
avoir un vaccin en juillet 2010
l'assemblée très très
loin aux bêtes à l'échelle de l'humanité
pas des animaux pour reconnaître easter
parce que c'est l'armée dans votre sujet
à parvenir sur la problématique
alimentaire c'est à dire qu'on l'entend
beaucoup attention à surpopulation
n'arrivera pas nourrir tout le monde a
oublié que c'est pas une question
uniquement de production que c'est une
question de distribution actuellement on
a bien assez pour nourrir toute la
population mondiale
simplement ce qui se passe avec la
nourriture elle va là où est l'argent
donc c'est encore une fois des
motivations économiques de profit qui
font que ça mal distribué ce que l'on
produit aussi c'est l'accaparement des
terres agricoles ce que l'on produit
aussi on reproduit de préférence pour
ceux qui ont les moyens de l'acheter
tout à fait et l'impact environnemental
il est beaucoup plus élevé pour les
populations industrielles et celles à
dire question aurait juste une minute
devait écrire un roman sur
l'effondrement armand collapse log on va
dire pour qu'est ce qui vous a attiré là
dedans en ce moment on sait qu'il ya
vraiment moyen du loup pour ça aussi des
maths dans la littérature c'est c'est le
portugais est ambitieux vous aviez un
vrai goût pour l'effondrement tu es
vraiment cet attrait pour la table rase
l'idée d'une reconstruction politique
oui c'est ce que celle après la
présentation chez les cols absolue
il faut savoir qu'il ya aussi des
théories en faveur d'un effondrement
graduelle lent alors bon pourquoi j'ai
choisi un effondrement brutal
évidemment parce que c'est plus
spectaculaire on va pas se mentir et un
peu plus grands de la crèche émotionnel
mais aussi parce que c'était la voie la
plus rapide vers cette table rase qui
permettait d'imaginer un autre mode avec
plus d'autonomie on a dit puis je crois
que les téléspectateurs des spectatrices
qui est qu'ils nous entendent
s'ils ont eu la chance de faire pousser
dans un jardin potager leurs propres
légumes ou fruits on sait bien que c'est
pas du tout la même satisfaction de
manger ça que d'acheter un
à nîmes et même faire son propre pain
c'est une tout autre satisfaction donc
pour moi c'est ça qui fait rêver c'est
quand même un monde beaucoup plus de
simplicité on pourrait rire maîtriser
nos productions maîtrisez au moins des
équipements qu'on pourrait réparer nous
mêmes après il ya toujours une
concentration de production spécialisés
ça c'est normal ça va ça va resté mais
quand on parle de la chine ont comparé
les technologies mais il ya des exemples
beaucoup plus bêtes par exemple 80% des
boutons à fermeture éclair du monde sont
produits dans une même ville qui au tout
en chine ça me paraît insensé merci tous
les quatre d'avoir participé à cette
émission merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]